what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news recently we
announced cloud services platform in
beta to help you modernize your apps
this week we're making things even
easier with a beta for CSP config
management allowing you to create a
consistent configuration for your
kubernetes resources in multi cluster
setups it even uses the native
kubernetes format such as yam or json
making it easy to get your existing
definitions applied to all of your
clusters as well as integrating with git
to make continuous integration simple
make a note to check out CSP config
management as soon as you can between
Google search Google Maps and YouTube
our products handle huge amounts of data
with high performance the technology
that keeps these running is available to
everyone through cloud BigTable which
now lets you globally distribute data
cloud BigTable is a managed wide column
no sequel database that can scale from
gigabytes to petabytes while still
maintaining high performance and low
latency with global replication you can
create multiple primary clusters so if
you're working with IOT finance ad tech
gaming or just about anything else check
it out speaking of huge amounts of data
Google Cloud Storage is a great place to
store unstructured data and you can
choose different ways to store that data
such as making sure it's served up
quickly using multi region or kept safe
using geo verdun net cold line we're
excited to share that cold line is now
cheaper and we have a new way to protect
you from unpredictable storage growth
the storage growth plan you can commit
to a fixed amount per month and not be
charged for any usage over your
commitment you can then renew after 12
months and your overage is free if it's
within 30 percent this is a great way to
better forecast your costs so try out
Google cloud storage and see if you can
save some cash now that you can store
that data the next step is probably
analyzing it and that means bigquery
we've just launched a new data analysis
quest to help you get up to speed on
using bigquery to troubleshoot common
sequel issues and to build your own
custom data visualizations even better
you can use the code 3G bigquery 785 to
get the first lab free so get started on
learning how to query petabytes and even
start to build machine learning models
get questing if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud